We’ve already determined that the Justice
League could probably take on the Avengers
in the first of our Marvel versus DC series,
but how do their villains match up?
Like the heroes, most villains have a near
equivalent in each the Marvel and DC Universes.
So which is the more dangerous universe to
live in?
To determine this we thought we’d see how
some of the films’ most famous villains
would fare mono e mono.
Green Goblin v Joker
The Joker and the Green Goblin can often be
seen sporting the same maniacal grin on their
faces.
Both insane in their own right, the Joker
definitely takes the crazy cake, but the Green
Goblin’s super powers and deadly gadgets
give him the edge here.
Let’s face it, the only reason the super
powerless Joker is still alive is because
Batman refuses to kill him, and you can be
sure the Green Goblin wouldn’t extend him
the same courtesy.
Loki v Zod
It would be a battle of Gods and Aliens if
General Zod were to take on the Norse God
of Mischief himself.
As a Kryptonian, Zod has most of the same
powers Superman man has: super strength, speed,
x-ray vision, and whole bunch of other badass
abilities.
As a God and member of the Frost Giants race,
Loki has many of the same powers as his adopted
brother Thor.
Whereas Zod is more military minded, Loki’s
mastering of magic and other trickery would
likely outsmart Zod’s maneuvers, making
this the another win for Marvel’s miscreants.
Magneto v Lex Luthor
On paper, there’s not much similar about
Lex Luthor and Magneto.
One was born with a silver spoon in his mouth
and the other was a holocaust survivor, yet
they’ve both risen as two of the most formidable
villains in their respective universes.
While Magneto could easily remove that silver
spoon from Lex’s mouth and turn any armour
Lex uses to protect his very human body into
a liability, the smartest man in the world
could surely find a way around Magneto’s
single power of controlling metal.
As an evil genius, Lex doesn’t need guns
or traditional man-made weapons that would
never work on Magneto, but could probably
think of a dozen other ways to take down the
X-Men’s fiercest foe, giving DC their first
win.
Apocalypse v Doomsday
Here’s a truly epic match up that would
make Batman v Superman look like a schoolyard
shoving match.
If Doomsday ever got on Apocalypse’s bad
side, it could literally mean the end of days
for everyone.
Both of these villains are able to adapt to
whatever you throw at them, making them practically
invincible and in Apocalypse’s case, immortal.
Doomsday does get bragging rights for killing
Superman, but we’re going to err on the
side of caution here and just call this one
a draw.
Whiplash v Bane
Neither Bane nor Whiplash possess any supernatural
abilities, but both have the brains and brawn
usually limited to body builders and scientists.
Both are pretty logical, so perhaps they’d
try to talk things out first, but with Bane’s
mask and Whiplash’s broken English this
probably wouldn’t get them very far.
Even with Whiplash’s mastering of Tony Stark’s
Iron Man tech, he was still unable to get
very close to taking down the hero, yet Bane
literally broke Batman, so we’re going to
have to give this one to Bane.
Mystique v Harley Quinn
With the count tied at two each and one draw,
we’re bringing out the villainous ladies
for the tie breaker.
Don’t be fooled by their looks, Mystique
and Harley Quinn are both as ruthless as any
evildoer in either universe and do not hesitate
to kill anyone in their path.
Quinn does have one major achilles heal which
is her dedication to the Joker, and with Mystique's
shapeshifting abilities, it wouldn’t be
hard for her to pose as the Joker to get close
to Quinn.
Once again, super powers trumps no powers,
and we’ll have to give this one to Marvel’s
Mystique.
So while DC is considered the darker universe,
it would seem that Marvel actually has deadlier
villains.
We’re basing this mostly on the movies,
so perhaps Suicide Squad will tilt things
in DC’s favor, but for now, it would seem
Gotham and Metropolis are safer places to
live than anywhere in the MCU.
Perhaps the Justice League isn’t stronger
than the Avengers after all, they just have
an easier job.